is earth the only livable planet in the
universe
what if earth was not even the only
livable planet
in our galaxy could we someday be living
on another planet
what if we lived on a super earth today
on what if disgust
[Music]
welcome to what if disgust i'm peter
smitchin and i'm richard garner
so pete if you had to describe our
planet
earth in one word one word what would
that word be
well i'm going to guess this is a trick
question and you're asking me this
because the title of our show today
which is super earth so i'm going to say
the earth is super
the earth is super yes but it is not a
super earth
according to current scientific
definition okay so again
super earth is a term that you know you
might have heard of over the last
really you know few years it's not it's
not much older than that it's
during this time where we're you know
finding a lot of exoplanets super
obviously meet a certain category and i
i won't uh continue to speculate i'll
i'll go to our friends at universe today
and their definition of a super earth
is a planet with more mass than earth
but less than a larger planet like
uranus or neptune so you could have
supers made of rock and metal
or even ice and gas these planets could
have oceans and atmospheres or made
of nothing at all like you know except
maybe hydrogen or helium
but the goal of course is to find a
rocky super earth
that's located in a habitable zone
so super ears aren't necessarily
conducive to human life but we're
looking
and we're continuing to look to find
that perfect sort of super earth
that might also be conducive to human
life yeah well we're not there yet
not there yet but it does seem like in
the past couple of years i mean i had
never heard the term habitable zone or
goldilocks zone before
and it seems like in the past couple of
years every every other week where
we're hearing about a new planet that
could potentially house
human life yes well 4 000 or so
exoplanets i believe something around
that have been discovered over the last
amount of years it feels like we're
going to be discovering more as we go
but yes it's gotten to the point where
it's not even like a big it's like
number seven on the list of news stories
on the site yeah we discovered a new
exoplanet before
it was like oh my god we discovered an
exoplanet now it's like we're like
whatever yeah is it possible to live
there hard for us to speculate but you
know who can
our guest today that's right let me
introduce you to him jack
madden graduated in 2014 from franklin
and marshall college with a ba
in astrophysics while at f m he worked
with dr fronfield crawford
on an extra galactic pulsar survey and
also on pulsar identification algorithms
he's now a fourth year phd student in
the department of astronomy
at cornell university dr madden thanks
for joining us
hey it's great to be here so we've heard
a lot over really the past few years
about
exoplanets and the discovery of
exoplanets and super
so it's an exciting time obviously to be
an astronomer
but for those people who aren't
astronomers um
it is a bit of a i don't know an enigma
that
all super earths are exoplanets but not
every exoplanet is a super earth do i
have that right
yes yeah uh and i apologize on behalf of
all
exoplanet scientists for the confusion
we we sort of use these terms um
loosely uh because we we know that
they're gonna change over time
uh so we started discovering all these
objects we needed a name
uh and we went with super earth and that
term has evolved
so the term is really uh how you might
describe
uh jupiter and saturn as like gas giants
it's sort of a subset a category of
planets that
is defined roughly by size so the term
super earth
it used to mean anything really between
an earth-sized planet and a uranus-sized
planet
but now we've really narrowed that down
to mean something that's
terrestrial something rocky like earth
that goes up to about 1.75
earth radii and that gives us a mass
between
one and maybe six or seven earth masses
how have advancements in technology and
specifically
telescope technology change the game in
searching the galaxy for
exoplanets super earths what can we
expect from the launches of the future
super telescopes because if you were
coming up right
yeah so astronomy is really driven by
the the design of telescopes um
you know we've seen thousands of
exoplanets discovered with
the capabilities of kepler uh tess
is gonna find a thousand more so we're
really looking now
towards characterizing these exoplanets
so we have all these planets what do we
do now we want to learn more about them
we don't know too much
just from their detection we know that
they exist
but what are they made of what are they
like on the surface
and the real push now is for uh
detecting
and looking at the atmospheres of these
super earth and rocky planets like the
earth
so that's where these these huge
telescopes come in and they're really
gargantuan these 30 meter class
ground-based telescopes and these sort
of 10 meter class
space-based telescopes that are still
concepts and those will have the
capabilities
of learning more about super earth
yeah it's an exciting time to be an
astronomer and your work specifically
uses
earth's own evolution to help with the
discovery
almost as a template to help discover
and find
super earths can explain to us how that
works yeah so
part of my research involves modeling
the climates
of potentially habitable exoplanets this
allows us
to sort of know what to look for and
know what to expect
as these measurements start to come in
and when you're dealing with
habitable planets we really only have
the earth
as the only example that we can build
our models off of
so when you build these models you need
sort of this ground truth to make sure
you're doing it right
and we don't want to venture too far
away from that
just so we know that we're doing it you
know within bounds of reason
based on the only example we have
but the trick is that the earth's
atmosphere has changed over time
it's been quite different in the past
but still
inhabited by life so we can
look at the geologic record and see what
the atmosphere was like on earth in the
past
and use those as templates
to a point where we don't have just one
example of a habitable planet but we
have several
but it's just the earth through time
what do we know currently about
exoplanets in terms of some of their
more
basic but vital measurements like oxygen
and atmosphere
levels yeah so these measurements are
really hard to make
we've mainly just found a bunch of
exoplanets
and the sort of special cases the
largest ones and the hottest ones are
things we can actually
get information about in terms of
composition
we haven't really looked at the
compositions of earth-like planets
very small colder planets so we don't
know too much there and that's where
these big telescopes are going to come
in
we do have some information about like
jupiter-sized planets and what their
atmospheres are structured like and what
those are made of but
nothing at the scale of an earth-like
planet
so let's talk gravity shall we
yeah well i mean in this particular case
it's probably and you correct me if i'm
wrong
uh you know the most important variable
we're dealing with we know how important
gravity is
as a force in the universe and obviously
as
as it affects life on this planet but
one of the things we also know is
gravitational pull
uh the bigger it is it affects uh you
know things like asteroids coming into
your orbit
we know about mass extinction events the
dinosaurs etc are some of these pot
these super earths potentially
living with maybe so much gravitational
force that
it might get in the way of them
developing long-term evolution and
civilization because
maybe they're getting pounded by
asteroids is that an oversimplification
no there there's definitely that's
definitely an interesting question
and i think there's a lot of competing
factors um
yes when you have a larger planet it's
going to have a greater
sort of sphere of influence
gravitationally
so it'll pull in more asteroids and
as they're coming in they're going to
speed up more because you have a greater
gravitational pull so they'll be faster
than if they were
coming into earth you have to though
consider that
um the main effect on the speed of an
asteroid
is really going to be the the relative
motion of the
planet and the asteroid as they orbit
their host star so the planet's going to
be orbiting around the asteroid is going
to be orbiting around too and those
velocities can be much higher
than if you were to sort of just drop an
asteroid
to a super earth there's also the effect
that these super earths might have
thicker atmospheres which can really put
the brakes
on a meteor um but so i think that
that expanded gravitational influence is
really gonna
cause some some interesting cases for
for asteroids and extinction events
which could be greater uh and so gravity
has not only effect on space debris like
asteroids and whatnot but
tell us about the effect of gravity and
how it pertains to
like water and magnetic fields and
and us yeah so there's a lot of theories
floating around about this and it's
really fascinating i think it's the most
fascinating thing about
super earth right now is is the strange
conditions they can create for these
different
things just based on their increased
gravity
[Music]
so things like the magnetic field uh
if you have more mass on a planet you
might actually end up
freezing sort of solidifying its dynamo
in its core
which actually could reduce its magnetic
field
there's there's theories maybe that
there's could be other
elements that could create a magnetic
field for these planets
but you might end up with a smaller
magnetic field
in terms of geologic activity a larger
planet is going to have more internal
heat
you might have more activity on the
surface
as that heat is trying to escape um
and then water is a really interesting
thing for
for superheroes i think it's one of the
most fascinating parts of this
to theorize about is that we're finding
some super earth that
might have a large fraction of water
so much greater than earth so these
planets might be covered
in a very deep ocean
[Music]
and what that does when you have a deep
ocean on a very massive planet
is you might actually get uh ice to
start to form at the
boundary between the ocean and the sea
floor
and this ice is very strange ice it's
not like ice we're used to
where the molecules are cooled down and
you know
crystallized into a solid this ice is
formed
just by the pressure alone so the
molecules are just packed so tightly
together that they form a solid
and this can have some really strange uh
consequences for things like
the evolution of life how plate
tectonics are working
and a whole host of different
cycles that affect the atmosphere
because you're sort of creating this
layer between the ocean and the seafloor
that's impenetrable usually water can
sort of interact with the rock at the
seafloor
you can transfer all sorts of chemicals
life can get started there once you put
this layer down
you're sort of stopping a lot of these
cycles and it can have some pretty
disastrous consequences if you think of
life starting
on the sea floor or how a planet might
regulate its temperature
uh in terms of these these like feedback
cycles
well i mean it's very interesting time
like i said to be an astronomer because
the
you know we're probably at the tip of
the iceberg in terms
of the discovery going forward with like
you talked about the improved technology
improved telescopes more exoplanets more
super earths
but still we've also sort of pointed out
is the question
still remains whether any of the
conditions on some of these
super earths are conducive to at least
creating life
that we would understand to be
quote-unquote intelligent life
but still more to unpack as we go
forward in the years
and decades to come uh thanks so much
for taking the time
to join us today to shed light on what's
really fascinating
uh a fascinating time to be alive uh to
be honest uh
where can people find more about your
fascinating work
yeah so you can look for my website
jmadden.org
on instagram and twitter or you can just
google me to find my
my recent papers uh yeah keep looking uh
looking in the uh the universe for us
and obviously
we hope that uh maybe one day we're
we're all talking about that great
discovery by
dr jack madden and if you're thinking of
planet names
peter richard just to consider
okay thank you uh and we'll catch up
with you down the line thanks so much
yep thanks so yes lots to
discover out there in the galaxy
exoplanets super earths but
for the time being our focus is still
here
on earth with our everyday issues and
our everyday problems one of those being
i don't know finding insurance
[Laughter]
well yeah it's uh it's you're right
because when you find
the right policy you save big bucks and
that's what we all want to do with
everything going on right now
richard in the world exoplanets aside
um people are asking is it even possible
to buy
life insurance are you asking that
question well it's a good question
because
in normal times you say of course it is
but now you know things
change when let's say risk goes up
people might be wondering is anybody
even selling life insurance and if they
are at what cost but obviously they
would need somebody to help
guide that process not only to find it
but also i guess to find the right one
policy genius uh yeah you can buy life
insurance during a pandemic and if you
have loved ones depending
on your income you definitely should
policy genius is an
insurance marketplace they're in contact
with insurance companies
on their platform every day keep keeping
track of all the changes in the market
so that you don't have to which means
you can get covered quickly
and for the best price here's how it
works policy genius
compares quotes from the top life
insurance companies
all in one place it just takes a few
minutes to compare quotes from the top
insurers
to find your best price this doesn't
save just legwork
like i say price you know how much you
could save richard
uh fifteen hundred bucks you how do you
know this
well i'm a genius you certainly are i'm
a policy you could save fifteen hundred
dollars
or more each year by using policy genius
to compare life insurance policies so
if you're one of the many people looking
to buy life insurance right now
but you're not sure where to start head
to policygenius.com policy genius will
find you the best rate
and handle the process completely
they'll get you and your family
protected
and give you one less thing to worry
about and again
plenty of things to worry about these
days every day which is why but why i
enjoy
uh you know a show like today because we
get to sort of zoom out
maybe out of our everyday issues and be
able to talk and think about things like
exoplanets
supers etc and we're lucky enough to
talk to people like dr jack madden
who has sort of opened our eyes to a few
different things i don't know about you
but i mean
first of all the the excitement about
what is to come not what's been
discovered
with these super telescopes that are
coming down the line i mean i i can't
even imagine i'm almost like a kid in
christmas because you can just sort of
you can speculate but
as far as where we're at now what we
understand i don't know one of the
biggest takeaways for me is that
you know kind of pump the brakes here we
the gravity
everything else i think the initial
exoplanets
meant other earths that were a bittable
like for a lot of people
super sounded like better earths yeah
yeah it doesn't sound like that
it's a misleading uh gnomer yeah it's a
misnomer
a misnomer if you will but it does sound
like
in the end the astronomers that are
working through different models
and obviously technology that we have
now have been able to speculate enough
things about atmosphere
oxygen levels and uh
gravity to feel pretty confident that
there's no discoveries as of yet where
we could say well there's probably an
intelligent species there at this
particular time
but tbd to be determined
to be determined well if you like this
episode and want to spend
more time on the topic click on the link
in the description below we have an
extended
audio version we'll be back with more of
dr jack madden in it and we'll have
carry on the conversation
with exoplanets super earths um
and anything else we can find out in
space yes
lots out there but thanks for joining us
today on what if discussed